what's life been like for you in this
past year
um it's been um
i've you know it's been a struggle to
some degree but
um i i moved into a new house
or actually a little cabin uh outside of
town right before the pandemic hit
and uh i got married about three years
ago so
um and i've been on the road for the
first two years so honestly the first
eight months of the pandemic were um
you know me getting to spend some time
at home getting used to a new place
um hanging out with hannah um
of course you know we planned on being
on the road that was disappointing but
um i try not to get too upset about
things i
can't control so when that happened i
switched gears and
and started writing new music and
getting ready for
you know 2021 and looking forward to
things opening back up so
i'm kind of bending that that switch
gears back to
trying to be creative and working on new
music and staying optimistic about the
future but it hasn't been as bad as i
know i know
i know a lot of people have gone through
a lot so i can't really complain because
things have not been too bad for for us
up here in nashville and
thankfully um you know we were able to
keep the other band and and we were able
to play just enough and doing
just enough to keep everybody rolling
and and um
so we haven't been in nearly the shape
that a lot of folks have been
in but i'm glad that things are finally
picking up
yeah i know everyone's looking forward
to new music but i'm kind of more
obsessed with
your chicken coop is that your chicken
coop did you see that picture
yeah yeah yeah that's my my chicken coop
i um
i can't take credit for building it my
brother-in-law who is
handier than i am around the farm he um
he built that um back six or eight
months ago but
um i got the chicks when they were just
you know probably
a few weeks old and did the we did the
hot hot lamp
in the in this big tub with uh
um you know feeding them for the first
little while and then they got big
enough to put out in the coop and
they've been out there laying eggs now
for
probably three or four months so i've
got a couple big bowls of egg i usually
do a couple eggs every morning
i haven't bought eggs from the grocery
store in about a year
that's amazing i'm a little bit like
every time i see someone with a chicken
coop i'm like
how how hard would that be to do for me
but i mean we're covered in snow right
now so i believe it's probably a no-go
for us
yeah it's it's where i recommend it if
you have a little space
if you ever have you know want to take
on a project and
maybe you don't get as many as i got i
got 10 originally and that was way too
many
uh we were like had
uh you know we had so many eggs we
couldn't eat them all so i gave a few
away
yeah oh good nice now you said that
you're back in the lab you're cooking up
some new music
um how is it how is it sounding compared
to what we've gotten from you in the
last little while
uh it's similar i work with a lot of the
same you know i work with the same
producer i'm working with a couple of
new guys
um but the sound itself in terms of
the production is still coming together
i haven't really recorded the song yet
actually i just recorded one song this
week and i'm snowed in we all got snowed
in down here in nashville
so um i didn't get a chance to go uh put
a vocal and sing on this song but
um or else we would have had it wrapped
up but um i would say
the sound is similar but the uh
perspective
um the the character in the songs has
evolved a little bit
changed right from a different place
different perspective
um i'm not i'm not writing from like
directly from my life as much on this
record i'm experimenting with
you know stepping outside of that that
more honest place although there is
there's going to be a lot of honesty in
these songs it's still you know country
music but it's um
experiment a little more with different
different perspectives different
scenarios
all right so what would you say what
would you say inspired that sort of
shift in perspective
um you know i
i guess just just wanting to
get for a little while i was i guess you
call it writer's block i got kind of
stumped for a little while because i was
you know we haven't really i haven't
really experienced a whole lot of
life in the last eight months outside of
just sitting around the house you know
like a lot of other folks
so um i'm trying to just
be creative and imaginative and just put
myself in different shoes and
draw on the past and also just scenarios
that maybe i haven't experienced but i
you know you imagine what it would be
like to experience
certain things certain um vantage points
different perspectives from different um
being in a relationship out of a
relationship heartbroken
optimistic about our relationship i mean
those nostalgia looking back those just
all those things that
now that my love life is a little more
steady
you know you have to draw from uh
scenarios that aren't necessarily
uh happening to you on a day-to-day
basis yeah right of course
how is she a good litmus test for your
music like do you run stuff by her
and does she should give you like a yes
or no or is that how does that work
yeah typically um but i have to make
sure
you know a lot of times when i'm you
know writing from different perspectives
i have to remind her that
you know don't read too much into these
lyrics because even though i've had
songs that maybe were
a little more honest not all my songs
are going to be directly about
my life and how i'm feeling at that
moment you know i may be stepping in the
shoes of a character
for a song so i have to be i have to be
careful
on certain songs to make sure she
doesn't read too much into uh
into the lyrics you know you
your music tends to write at least for
me it rides the line between like
the country flavor classic country
lyrics songwriting and your voice of
course
and a different sort of sound you know
bringing in sounds from hip-hop bringing
sounds from all over the place
is that the direction that you want to
continue going moving forward sort of
experimenting with your sound
blending different things together um
yeah i would like to uh to some degree
but
um you know
for something to sound fresh it you know
you
it needs to be relatively rare in the
ethos
and over the past i don't know four or
five years a lot of that
sound has been you hear it a lot you
hear those 808 drums everywhere now and
like you hear
um certain a certain sound
everywhere now so i mean a sound some of
those
some of that instrumentation some of
that production that may have been
sounded original a little more original
and a little more fresh four or five
years ago
now we've all heard those sounds those
drum sounds and those
instruments the instrumentation that
production a lot more so
i try to evolve and not just lean on the
same old trick so i'm experimenting
a little bit now you know now my ear
because i've heard so much of that
hip-hop element my ear is drawn to
to songs that i hear on the radio now
that are a little more stripped down and
raw
when i hear just a you know an acoustic
guitar or like a nylon string guitar
with
maybe still mix in some of those some of
those drum sounds because that that is
a um signature part of uh sorry
i have my studio a little mic here
ringing that it that was kind of a
signature part of the sound early on but
i want to be able to evolve and
experiment with different sounds so um
i don't want to get stuck in that same
lane you know
you've gotten such a you've gotten to a
great spot where you are right now
in terms of your music what you're
putting out there people knowing you
what is a job that you used to have
before you were able to say that you
were a full-time musician that you were
very happy you never have to do again
uh that's pretty easy that one uh would
be
um moving i worked
for a moving company um
one summer when i was several years ago
and we were moving i don't know two or
three
houses a day and
that was hard hard hard work and
you know i needed a job and i
appreciated having that job and
i would do it again if i had to but i'm
thankful that uh
that i'm not having you know
having to lift heavy dressers and beds
and couches and
you know all day long i i hurt my back
back in college playing football i don't
know if i can handle it now
oh man what what piece of advice
did someone give to you when you were
younger starting out
that you found to be true throughout all
your years
that you would that you would pass down
to somebody else
um you know i never really
um i don't remember a specific moment in
time
when someone said something to me that
resonated
in a way that you know i never forgot
that moment and can remember those
specific words
um you know just
so there's not really any any quotable
advice that i
that i've gotten and remembered but i i
do think that my time
playing uh football was really helpful
a lot of the men who are who become
coaches in that in that realm
are very disciplined they hard work is
very important
character doing the right thing
um you know if you say you're going to
do something do it like
a lot of the um
the part of my character that's been
important in terms of
you know just generally writing wrong
doing writing
what's right and not what's wrong and
and discipline and hard work and all
those things you know that that
typically you associate with success i
learned a lot of that with
through those through through those
experiences with football so
it wasn't really a moment in time but i
think being around those
um you know they were they were
hard-nosed tough
men who um you know they were they were
hard on us
through those years and pushed us to be
to reach our potential but
i think a lot of uh the discipline that
i have now to to work hard comes from
that era um and it was that was
collective
advice you know that came from a lot of
different great men that i was around
who
you know helped help instill you know a
lot of those values and that
that's definitely given me a competitive
advantage in
music because when i came to town i you
know i've been playing guitar for a year
or two
i didn't know much about songwriting but
i did have
a work ethic and a lot of folks who were
very very talented who i
you know spent time around when i first
got to town they just
they took it serious but they you know
they like to get out and have a good
time and
i like to have a good time as well but i
worked worked really hard early on and i
think that
paid off yeah i think your focus is
definitely paying off you must also be
focused on
not just now but the future what's left
on your bucket list that you still
want to do it that you haven't done yet
in terms of music
um
that's a good question i um
i'd really like to make some records
down the road that are
um i guess more a little more
singer-songwriter a little less
um concerned with
you know i don't want this to come
across the wrong way but a little less
concerned with with
genre and touring and and
any part of the business that that has
influenced
my decision-making in terms of making
music that didn't really
influence me early on but i over the
years it has gradually
become a part of the process that i
consider you know
for better or worse and i think
sometimes better sometimes worse
but um to really just free myself of all
that
influence and and just make a record
you know not really worried about
anything other than just
you know do i feel something when i'm
writing these songs and i try to do that
now but
i can't say that it's it's in its purest
form at this point but i'd like to be
able to do that down the road
that's artistic freedom right that
people are always trying right right
yeah yeah
and you gotta you gotta consider being
able to when especially early on you
gotta consider being able to
you know pay your rent and um
put food on the table and and but uh you
know as the time's going on
uh um i think i've considered the
economic side of it too much and i'd
like to
lean back out of that frame of mind
frame
and uh focus back on just the music
which i'm trying to do now
but i think i could progress to a point
where i could be completely free of that
nice well i i'm looking forward to
talking to you when you feel like you've
reached that spot man
well i appreciate that man all right all
the best take care
thanks see you man